ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello,
and welcome.
Another exciting episode of
Google Developers Live.
This is Google Apps Unscripted,
Google I/O 2013 edition.
And my name is Arun Nagarajan.
And we're coming live from
the New York studio.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, hi.
And I'm Eric Koleda, also a
member of the Apps Script
Developer Relationships Team.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
Eric and I haven't been on
air together in a while.
I just realized that as
I saw ourselves in the
monitor right here.
Super excited to
be on the air.
And in today's episode, we're
going to, of course, talk
about Google I/O 2013, which we
just wrapped up last week.
ERIC KOLEDA: Amazing
event, wasn't it?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Amazing
event, amazing event.
Still catching up on all the
other things that I've missed,
but super high energy, really
nice to be out there and meet
a lot of the developers that
work on our product, you
folks, and also just to talk
to other people that are
working on really cool stuff.
In today's episode, we're going
to focus on recapping
the session from last week, the
big product launches we
had, a lot of really
exciting things.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it was a
good time for App Script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good time for
App Script, as I think last
year of IO was, as well.
And most importantly, we want
to take questions from you.
So there's a Google moderator
link, where I think I've
already seen a bunch of good
questions come up.
And we'll also have some live
questions towards the end.
So please, put your questions
in moderator or be prepared
with the questions
towards the end.
And we'll make sure we save
plenty of time for that.
So first things first, let's
talk about all of
the exciting launches.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So if you've
seen our blog posts, I think
this went on, I think, the day
before I/O. And then these
were available, I think, a few
hours before that even.
So the big launches, I think
there were, I counted, five
big launches.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Probably the
biggest one was scripts in
Google Docs.
One of the top requested
features for a long time.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think
since scripts was in
Spreadsheets, people naturally
thought, why
not my docs, right?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
I think Spreadsheets was
a really good teaser.
And a lot of people saw
the power of it.
And obviously, a lot of
Spreadsheets specific use
cases still apply.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But once you
have that natural inclination
to script and automate things
and be able to do stuff with
content in a document, you want
to do it in Google Docs.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And I guess if you've used App
Script a lot in the past,
well, there's always been
a Document app, right?
That's been out for a while.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Not always, but
for at least a while now.
But I think we took it a step
further now where it's not
just that you can manipulate
your document.
You can actually put a script
within a document.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right, and a lot
really cool things that I
think we did a really fantastic
job with the
session, as well, where the team
showed off a really cool
demo that they built.
Jonathan [? Rascher ?], who was
one of the presenters, I
think did a terrific job and set
the stage for what we've
done with the script
service here, the
document service here.
And a lot more to
come, I'm sure.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I think one of the most exciting
parts about the new
Google Docs integration
is the sidebar.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right
ERIC KOLEDA: So we've had the
ability to show pop ups in
Spreadsheets before and
other UI adjustments.
But the sidebar, I think,
although it's kind of just
like a dialogue that sticks to
the side, it really opens up a
lot of whole new use
cases that we
think are really exciting.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So I think a pop up's
obviously modal.
They take you out of the
flow if you're a user.
Having a sidebar up and having
you still be able to work on
the content is, I think,
really powerful.
And the set of use
cases that that
enables is really powerful.
And we're super excited see what
you can build with it.
So that was a big one.
The next one I know that's near
and dear to your heart is
the form service.
Google Forms, obviously there
was a really good re-launch of
that product with lots of new
features in first quarter, I
think it was?
Maybe March, April?
ERIC KOLEDA: Right, yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Maybe
even before.
I forget the exact date.
But the natural inclination
again was to be able to
automate and extend
that set of APIs.
So we added a brand new service
called Form Service
and also brought in all the
capabilities of the UI
integration, the trigger
capabilities
within Google Forms.
So this, you did a session
on this actually.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
It was a lot of fun.
Me and one of the engineers
who builds Forms and has
worked a lot on the App Script
side as well, we did a
co-presentation at I/O about how
you can use App Script and
Forms together.
And Forms, it used to be
not its own product.
It was just a different feature
of Spreadsheets.
Now, it's graduated into its
full product and own product.
I think it makes
a lot of sense.
Forms is really widely used.
Very popular for collecting
data, especially in schools
and other organizations.
And so now, adding scripting
to that just
made a lot of sense.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And the format that
you can use to manipulate
Forms, we built it from
the ground up.
It's really good.
It's really complete.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, I
really like the API.
It just felt very natural
to play with it.
And we like to call
Google Apps as the
productivity suite.
And Forms make you
more productive.
And the fact that you can script
against these forms,
that just takes it off
the charts, I think.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh,
yeah, totally.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I was just
think about, obviously it's
really big in education and
personal use and whatnot.
And I just see so many use cases
that people have already
started to do.
And Andrew Stillman's already
put out a couple
of scripts, I think.
I think it was two scripts,
two separate scripts he's
already built.
So really excited to see
where all of that goes.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think in one of
his videos he described Forms
as the paper clip
for MacGyver.
It's this tool that you use to
get out of any situation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Every episode!
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And that's what I tihnk Forms
is to a lot of teachers.
And so having the scripting
capablities just makes it that
much more powerful.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And I really encourage you
to play with this one.
It's really easy to play with.
The API is really
nicely designed.
And I think this, more than
anything else, I feel like
there's nothing in the UI that
you can do that you can't do
in the API.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's true.
Yeah, he really made it every
check box, every kind of item,
it's in there.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you'd find
it in the place you'd expect
to find it, too, which
is the nice thing.
The next thing is the
new Drive service.
So you have probably already
seen this as well in your
script editor and auto-complete
and all that
good stuff.
We call it Drive App.
It's a brand new service that
encapsulates the Drive API, so
the Drive SDK, which
launched last year.
Provides a brand new way to
interact with the documents
and files you have
in Google Drive.
And we now have exposed
that API as a
service in App Script.
Really powerful, a lot of
really nice things.
John McGowan, who was a
co-presenter with me on this
session, we talked about
this launch.
And we're pretty excited about
this one, as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think
it's pretty cool.
In some ways, you can look at
it and say, ah, I could do
that via Docs list.
Right?
What's new?
I think some of the key things
to remember is while we did
add a couple new features,
like I think owner
manipulation was one of them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That
was a big one.
ERIC KOLEDA: That was a big one,
especially when people--
I know a lot of organizations
having people leave and change
roles, makes it really
important to have.
But even just beyond that, I
think one of the key things is
that in App Script, we're taking
all these other parts
of Google and connecting them.
And when we change our
technology to go on to the
latest kind of new underpinning,
so now that
we're on the same Drive
infrastructure as the external
Drive SDK, it makes it so that
we can bring in features a lot
more quickly.
We can respond to feature
requests.
There's so much more data we
can expose to you now.
And so we launched, I
think, with what was
more of a parity version.
We wanted to have the same
features, capabilities as Docs
list, give or take.
But now, we have the ability
that if there's another little
bit of information you need
from your Drive, from your
files, we have a lot easier
way to actually
bring that to you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And one of the examples that
John gave was the ability to
search much more interesting
parameters.
And Docs list has some
search capabilities.
But now, you can have the same
searching capabilities that
you have through the Drive API,
the one you use HTTP and
RESTful services for,
in App Script.
So when you're asking for
questions on "Stack Overflow,"
there's a wider community of
developers that can support
you and help you.
And like Eric said, when the
Drive team makes improvements
to their service, a lot of that
will now be available in
App Script in a more appropriate
timeframe.
One thing I do want to make sure
is on the record is that
I mistakenly said during my
session that Docs list was
deprecated.
It is not deprecated.
It is still marked
as experimental.
And we do recommend you go
to the new Drive App API.
We think it's really easy
to convert your code.
But if you're using Docs list,
it's not deprecated.
So I apologize for
that confusion.
And I know Eric, you caught up
on that right as I said it in
my session.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
We're not trying to make any
alarm bells go off, right?
You don't need to start
rewriting all
your scripts today.
If you're writing a new script,
I would really, really
strongly recommend you look to
the Drive App because I think
it's going to give you the
features you need, and maybe
even some features that you
didn't have before.
But for now, everything you
wrote will continue to run.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
And I did add a little comment
in the video recording of the
I/O session that I was
wrong about that.
So I apologize again
for that confusion.
Great.
So those are the new APIs
that we launched.
We also improved some
existing stuff.
So that the big one that I am
pretty excited about that
really enabled a lot of the cool
demos that we showed off
was the faster HTML service,
which comes via an
experimental flag around the
mode for the sandbox in which
your code runs, your
HTML code runs.
And we call it ES5,
or ECMAScript 5.
It basically enables
strict mode.
And you do it through a set
sandbox code API call on top
of your HTML service output.
And it's a really
straightforward one, easy to
find in the auto-complete.
But we also have some
documentation we'll show you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, and if you've
ever seen us on Apps
Unscripted before, every time
someone asks an HTML service
question or mentions a problem,
we usually throw out
the word "KAHA," right?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
the sandbox.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's become kind
of almost a negative
connotation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
ERIC KOLEDA: But essentially,
the sandboxing, we want to
keep the user safe from
malicious code.
What that usually means is that
we end up putting a lot
of chains around the code
that you write.
So with this new sandbox method,
it relies much more on
native browser features.
Which means that everything
runs faster.
There's less restrictions.
And generally, developing on
HTML services is a lot more
friendly now.
So we have made it an
opt-in for now.
We didn't want to force
it on people.
But we do recommend if you
have a script, opt in.
Just try it on your
development mode
for your web app.
See if it's--
most cases I've seen, everything
still runs, and it
runs faster.
And so I think they'll
really enjoy it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, and
it's required for some--
if you want to start playing
around with Bootstrap, for
instance, some of the layout
capabilities that that
provides, and the styling
capabilities.
It's required for those
advanced APIs.
And like Eric said, it actually
runs faster in most
of the scenarios I've done--
pretty much all scenarios
I've tested.
So that's really exciting.
Play with it.
Let us know what works, what
issues you're still having.
And we look forward to continue
to improve that and
providing you more options
on that front.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I guess we
should warn upfront that while
it does allow things like
Bootstrap and other frameworks
to work, we know already
it's not 100%.
So we're really interested
in Angular.
It's one of my favorite
JavaScript frameworks.
And there's still some
problems there now.
The team that's still
working on all the
sandboxing is on the ball.
They know about this, and
they're working on it.
But a lot more is possible.
But just not everything.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup,
yup, definitely.
And we're pushing hard on it.
The next one that's also
an improvement is the--
also experimental, I should
say-- is the improved
authorization flow.
This is actually one of the
things that I've been turning
on in all my projects,
all my new projects.
It basically gives you a really
nice, consolidated
authorization screen that the
users see, that you as the
developer see when you run it
for the first time from the
script editor, where you no
longer have to go through
potentially multiple pop-ups
that look different.
And also, you don't have to
run your script again if
you're from the script editor.
I think you enable this
by going File, Enable,
Authorization, and New
Authorization Mode, or
something like that.
I forget exactly what that is.
Upgrade Authorization
Experience is the
menu option we use.
So under File, Upgrade
Authorization Experience.
We highly recommend you test it
out in your test projects.
But it's one of those things
that I think makes your user
more comfortable
with your app.
It looks like the other
authorizations screens that
they see potentially with Chrome
Apps, and Drive Apps,
other general OAuth2-looking
screens.
It's a consolidated set of
scopes that we ask for on
behalf of you without you having
to work on those scope
declarations actively.
And I just think it
looks a lot nicer.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I was going
to say, we have some really
great engineers.
They do not really
fit the bill of
a UI designer sometimes.
So the orange, the red box
around the warning panel.
Sometimes it's green, or
sometimes it's yellow.
It's Times New Roman.
It's not exactly the
most appealing.
And so I know in the past, the
language, and the colors, and
the look have scared
some users off.
So this new flow goes through
standard Google
authorization dialogues.
And so it looks very,
very familiar.
Very clean, very appropriate.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And another
thing I like about it is that
you, as a developer, your email
address is not exposed.
So it's actually
a subtle thing.
But in the previous
authorization screen, it would
say, last edited by, or owned
by, and the two email
addresses, if not the same,
will also be exposed.
And with the new OAuth 2 screen,
all it says is what
the project name is, and what
scopes it's requesting for.
And I think that's a lot nicer
for everyone involved rather
than just seeing some gmail.com
address I think.
So yeah, so little, subtle
things that I think helps both
end users and the developers.
So that's one of the things
that's really nice.
The other thing is that it
actually creates a developer
console project for you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
I was going to throw
it out there.
So you don't need a
developer console
project to use App Script.
But some of our advanced
services, we have a URL
Shortener service, an Analytic
service, an AdSense service.
To enable those advanced
services, you do
need to have a project.
So previously, we'd advise you
to go to this other URL, and
set up a project.
Now, we are automatically
creating a project for you
just when you create
the script.
So there's still a little bit
of setup where you need to
toggle on and agree to some
terms and conditions.
But it cuts down the setup a
lot, and that's what allows
you to hide the email
addresses.
We're using the name of that
console project in order to do
the authorization screens.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And this kind of bridges
the gap from you
now have the script.
But now, you're a professional
developer.
Or you brought in a professional
And you want to take advantage
of these other Google APIs and
services and all of the cool
things that you get from the
API console.
You're able to now bridge that
gap from this script editor
itself, which I think
is great.
So pretty good list of things.
So yeah, we're pretty excited
about it, as you can tell.
And I think we showed off all
of these in some form or
another at Google I/O. And we're
really excited to take
this further.
And I think what we want the
most is your feedback.
And I want to make sure you like
what we delivered, and
what we can improve,
and what are some
of the things missing?
And we're really looking
forward to
a lot of that feedback.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, definitely.
And we haven't stopped,
either.
We're still chugging ahead.
After we got back from I/O, all
the engineers went right
back to work working
on new features.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I don't think
anyone took a day off.
ERIC KOLEDA: So even with all
these launches, we know
there's still so much
more people want.
And even just, people have
already asked for, where can I
get the sidebar in
my Spreadsheet?
And so Jonathan is hard on the
case of making that happen.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
There's a lot of things that
we can continue to improve.
But yeah, what would really
encourage us is to see what
you're building and the use
cases that you are not able to
achieve because this small
API is missing.
So keep sending that positive
feedback or constructive
feedback over.
And we're looking forward
to working and
delivering on those.
Great, so those are
the features.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about what we did at I/O
specifically.
So we had four sessions.
Which is I think--
ERIC KOLEDA: I think it's
the most we've ever had.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Most we've ever
had, so really exciting.
Three of them in the Chrome
and Apps track, and one of
them in the YouTube track.
So do you want to start off with
the two that you're most
familiar with, the Forms one,
which you delivered, and the
Scripts and Google Docs?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So I mentioned the Forms
earlier when we
talked about Forms.
Me and Matt, we presented
on Forms.
Kind of just a good overview
of what it means to be
integrated into Forms, how the
format works, some brief
sample code to give
you a feel of it.
And then, going into a little
bit about why it's useful.
We talked a lot about
mini-workflows.
The idea that there's some work
you have to do in your
organization that's kind of
just pushing data around.
And why have a human push data
when computers can do it?
So we really think having Forms
plus scripting allows
you to get people out of the
picture, solve these problems.
So the demo that we showed
off, which I thought was
really cool, was around
educators.
So it was the idea of a
quick quiz creator.
I think you did a quiz
script also.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Completely code centered.
ERIC KOLEDA: Very popular
use case.
And also makes great demos.
So our quiz creator allowed you
to spin up a form really
quickly, email it to students,
and then live see their
responses that trickle in.
So we have that video up.
Actually, all of the
videos are up now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So for anything we
talk about here, you can go
watch the full video
afterwards.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And then, I think
the other one is--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Scripts
and Google Docs.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, the Google
Docs presentation.
So that was by our
PM, Saurabh.
And also co-presenting
with Jonathan.
And their presentation was
focused around Bibstro.
Bibstro is a script that they
built that I guess is a
bibliography management sidebar
app for Google Docs
that was conceived
in a bistro.
Thus, bibstro.
And they kind of talked you
through how they built it, the
technologies they used.
And I think it showed off
all the different parts.
They manipulated a doc.
They read a doc.
They showed a sidebar.
They had a menu item.
They really took you through
the full suite of
functionality.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
that was one of the
live streamed events.
And I actually had to watch
it live because
the room was so packed.
And I needed some alone time.
But the live stream, I
thought it was just
such a packed event.
There was just so
much content.
The demo itself was awesome.
But then, they walked through so
much detail about the DOM,
or the document object model,
for Google Docs.
The APIs, various APIs to get at
modify all the good stuff,
and how the sidebar and the
menus were injected itself.
So I'd highly recommend you
check out the videos.
And it's a reason why
we record them.
We think even if you were there
or you watch it live, I
think some of these videos are
worth checking out a couple of
times because we really do
pack in a lot of content.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, totally.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So the other two
sessions, both of them I
guess I ran.
I'll talk first about the
one in Chrome and Apps.
So this one was all about
Google Drive.
How you can have a Google Apps
Script developed app available
in the Google Drive UI in the
Create menu, and then have
your app invoked when
you click on a file.
That's the first part about
integrating into the
Google Drive UI.
And second part was all about
accessing the files in drive
from App Script.
So again, we kind of told a
story through an example,
through a demo that involved a
teacher publishing a Google
Docs based quiz out to a
lot of the students.
So there's a roster of student
email addresses and a template
quiz that has, let's say,
five or six questions.
The teacher's able to take the
set of student emails, and
then assign each student a
copy of that quiz that's
shared with only the right
person automatically.
And then, at the end of the
deadline, the teacher's able
to take away the edit rights
from the student and then only
make them a viewer.
So that was kind of a story
around publishing
and closing a quiz.
And then, all about all the
different APIs were on
creating documents, managing
permissions,
all that good stuff.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it's
funny because--
when I was working on the quiz
script in Forms, I originally
tried to do a version where
it was free form answer.
But then, there was no
way to score it.
I feel almost like we have
complimentary quiz scripts.
I could make a multiple
choice form.
And blast that out.
And then, you could do an--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Essay form.
ERIC KOLEDA: An essay form.
And then, they can collect all
of those, and review them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
If you're a teacher, a great
time to be a Google Apps user.
So that was really a
nice set of demos.
And John kind of talked through
some of the new APIs
including the set owner feature
that we added, and the
ability to restrict
a Doc from being
forwarded to other people.
So only the editor can
change permissions.
So previously, this was
something that you couldn't do
through the Docs
API, I believe.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Sometimes, you know, there's
just one extra checkbox, or
one extra method that we add.
But then I forget that
sometimes, that can completely
make or break a use case.
Like having sometimes a student
be able to share
something out to the world
with their friends, that
completely breaks the system.
So these things are small, but
sometimes really important.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And again goes back to more
of the parity with the
UI and the API there.
So that was really
a nice session.
And then, the other session I
did was actually out of the
Chrome and Apps track.
It was with a new set
of developers.
Hello, all, if you're watching,
YouTube developers.
And it was all about YouTube,
we recently announced, a
billion unique monthly viewers,
which is crazy.
That's a big number,
unique monthly
viewers, a billion people.
I was blown away
by that figure.
But those people, they're
producing a lot of analytics.
And as content creators, you
want to be able to manage
them, a better interface to
look at that data and make
meaning out of it.
And you don't want to
necessarily write a whole
separate app for that.
And what we came up with was
using App Script to pull the
data from the Google Analytics
API into a spreadsheet with a
set of focused scenarios around,
I just want to chart
this particular dimension and
metric data that's available.
Or I want to look at this data
in a geospatial map.
Or I want to be able to automate
something, and
integrate something with maybe
Twitter analytics data,
something like that.
So those are just setting up a
bunch of scenarios and give
them some starter code.
And it was actually pretty
well received.
And a whole bunch of developers
that had never
heard about App Script
now know it exists.
And they were all really excited
because their business
users, who are nontechnical
people, now have potentially a
tool that works in a spreadsheet
that they're
comfortable, that they don't
have to know all the coding
terminology around.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I used to
think of a spreadsheet as a
way to store data.
I've come to think of it almost
like a UI builder.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: A simple
application layer.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's a read-write
layer around data, as well as
an extra tools for charting
and things like that.
So when you want to spin up
something quickly, you don't
want to invest a lot of
resources and building a
custom app, dumping into a
spreadsheet, and manipulating,
saving, updating, graphing,
doing it all there lowers the
barrier to entry.
Where you could get something
up in a day, hand it to
business folks.
And then, they can actually
start getting value from it
immediately.
It doesn't take a whole cycle
of design, development,
review, deployment.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
So I think those are some of
the things at I/O. Very
quickly, I'll also mention some
really good partners that
were there.
Avery Dennison showed off how
you could take a Spreadsheet
and then be able to do an
envelope merge out of it.
We had Hello Fax shown
off, faxing services
from a Google Doc.
DocuSign showing off e-signature
services, and Turn
It In showing the ability to
take an assignment and submit
it from within Google Docs.
So thanks for those partners,
and a few others that were
there showing off some really
really cool stuff.
Very quickly, I'll show of where
you can find the videos.
So we have a playlist here on
the screen that shows off all
the different videos
from Google I/O
2013 with App Script.
And you can find them from our
home screen if you just go to
the bottom right corner.
There's a playlist that
you can see to
catch up on older episodes.
Very easy to find.
Highly recommend watching the
four episodes, four sessions
if you haven't seen
them already.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it's great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Speaking of
documentation, a couple of
pretty exciting things that our
tech writer Dan launched
right before.
In all of these launches, we
did so much launches that
sometimes those little
things got lost.
But I think they're
really great.
So in addition to just all
this new reference
documentation around Form App,
and Drive App, and all the new
things in Documents, we all
published some other great
documentation.
Some of it is related to these
new launches, and some isn't.
So at the top of your
screen here, we have
some new quick starts.
So our goal was to have
more of these five
minute quick starts.
So that if you're new to
scripting, really quickly you
can see the power, get
some sample code,
start playing around.
So we have one focused on
Spreadsheets, which is using
some of the technology that's
been around for a while.
And then, another one focused
more on Forms, but also its
integration with Calendar,
Docs, and email.
And so it really takes you
through a pretty real life use
case, although it's a conference
for monsters where
they have the most
real real life.
But certainly, if you replaced
monsters with something more
boring, it would seem
appropriate.
We also have then some new
user guides, one for HTML
service, which we're
highlighting here.
So you mentioned that the HTML
service, we added some new
sandboxing capabilities.
But we also realized that it was
a bit hard to get started.
There was so much text,
so much documentation.
And so tech writer Dan did an
amazing job of reorganizing
it, making it clear, doing
a lot of work.
He also separated it out
into concrete sections.
So it's the kind of thing you're
not going to probably
read it every day.
But if you give it a read
through, or if you come back
and reference it as you're
developing, it's a really
great tool for that.
And then, the other one is for
Google Docs, since we always
had this Document app, but we
didn't ever give you a ton of
information about how a doc
is laid out, and how you
manipulate it.
We put together, or Dan did,
this guide that shows you the
structure of a Google Doc, what
parts are manipulatable,
what parts are read only, as
well as a whole bunch of other
extra information about common
tasks, like replacing text.
So if you want to start getting
more into Docs, doing
more doc manipulation, more
reading and writing, this is
also a great resource.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Ton of really good stuff.
All right, I think we are
actually running low on time,
which is crazy.
Too much talking.
Let's go to questions?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, do
we have anybody in
the Hangout, I wonder?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Any
live questions?
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh,
I see someone.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: First, I'm [? Linni ?]
from Louisiana.
First, I'd just like to give
you all kudos, man.
I am not a programmer.
And the work I've done with
our company has completely
changed our operation through
using App Script and Google
and all of that stuff.
So first off, kudos.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I always have a ton
of questions, but I figured
just ask you all one.
Is maybe a best practice
scenario on pulling data in
before loading it
into the HTML.
So like, I've written a couple
of the HTML stuff, and they go
to a spreadsheet to get
the information.
And I think that's where a lot
of the slowdown is obviously.
Is there a best practice
on doing that?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that's good.
So definitely, spreadsheet
reading can be slow,
especially if you do it like
get range, get value, get
range, get value, get
range, get value.
If you get a whole giant range
at once and get all the values
at once, it can be
a lot faster.
But even then, it's not a high
throughput data store.
It's not meant to do a ton of
reads and writes with a lot of
efficiency.
It's more--
spreadsheets are based around
user friendliness, not around
speed optimization.
So if you're trying to throw
some content from a
spreadsheet into a UI, it
definitely helps to fetch it
all at once, and then hand
if off to your UI.
Or you may want to look into
other things, like using our
caching layer with a Cache
Service to perhaps, if you
know your spreadsheet data's not
going to change during the
course that the script is
running, maybe throw the data
into the cache.
And then access it via
the cache later.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So I think that's the two
high-level bullets that are
really important, I want to
repeat are, try to get big
chunks at once.
And then, process in memory.
And then, also use the caching
service so that maybe if your
spreadsheet's not updating
more than once every two
minutes, put it in the cache
for 15, 20 minutes or
something like that.
All right, let me go to the
moderator here really quickly
because there are some really
good questions in there that
I'll skip through here.
So the first question was
around, any more background to
the statement, to plan for the
future, we recommend you
migrate to HTML services?
I think that statement's
still true.
But we will continue to invest
more in HTML service.
You saw what we added with the
new sandbox capability.
We hope to have better
documentation.
You saw what Dan has done
with the new API guides.
UI App is not deprecated.
UI GUI Builder was.
So UI App will still
be around.
So if you have new apps, we
highly recommend using HTML
service because that's where
we're investing the energy.
But UI App is still there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
If you've seen some of the demos
that maybe we showed off
during Google IO this year in
our sessions, some of those
things just could not
be built via UI App.
So really, we think that HTML
service requires a little bit
more work, and we're working
on making it so that the
ramp-up time isn't
quite as hard.
And hopefully, it'll be easier
and easier to use.
But we do think that the
power it unlocks makes
it worth the effort.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yup.
And we'll work on ways to
have transition guides.
We'll keep working on that
informally as well.
So some other things around, the
next question's about not
getting the same options in get
events versus get events
by series ID.
It is a known limitation
at this point.
We're investigating,
I should say.
Moving to a new Calendar API.
There's some new options
available to
us in the back end.
So we were going to
investigate that.
And hopefully that will enable
some of these new APIs.
Nothing to announce at this
point, but point taken.
And the next one's actually
one of my favorites.
The error messages today are not
so helpful, this gentleman
or lady writes here, around when
something wrong happens,
something bad happens.
So there are a couple
things you can do.
In your code itself, you can do
a better job of having some
more try catches, especially
in the hot areas where, if
you're doing a lot of file
writes, maybe try to have that
on try-catch so you know
what is failing.
So the try-catch works.
It's just standard JavaScript.
So that's a really good
way to do it.
And besides that, we know we
have some work to do as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, part
of it is that--
one day, one of our lead
engineers drew a system
diagram of how App
Script works.
And the number of boxes and
systems on the whiteboard that
day was overwhelming.
So we connect to so
many systems.
And if one of them has an
unfortunate outage for a
little bit of time,
we get an error.
Now, if we gave you that
message, that message doesn't
provide you any meaning.
It's some internal message
about an internal system.
So a lot of times, we
just wrap it all
up in server error.
I know that feels really
frustrating.
Like, why does everything
say server error?
That's not telling
me anything.
But whatever we told you would
be just as meaningless, the
random back end name of
some tool we use?
It's not going to give you
the information you need.
And a lot of times if it's a
server error, we're saying
it's our fault.
We're sorry.
But it's not probably
a mistake that
you're making in code.
So I think you're spot on.
You can identify what portion
of your code is
throwing that error.
So perhaps you could work around
that for the time being
or take it out of your flow.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
there might be
an issue you identify.
And that'll be really helpful
to us when you log it in the
issue tracker if you can isolate
the area that is
potentially throwing an error.
So if you're weaving Drive calls
with Calendar calls with
Translate calls, there
might be certain
things that may break.
But if you're writing your code
in a way such that you're
able to trap that yourself,
that'll really help us and I
think yourselves as well.
Next question, any plans on
integrated HTML GUI Builder?
As of now, no plans.
Our goal is to support
the most popular HTML
capabilities.
So there are plenty of
other really good GUI
builders out there.
Our hope is that by supporting
the standard, you're able to
bring your own tools and use
what you're already familiar
with or is your favorite.
Would you agree?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, spot on.
I think we're thinking that App
Script, our real power,
what people love about App
Script is the ability to go
right to your Gmail, right
to your Calendar, right?
So we're putting more
of our efforts into
doing what we do best.
And we think that there's so
much evolution in the web, in
design, in UIs.
Let's use the best of what's out
there, and bring that into
App Script, rather than for us
to invent another builder.
And then, it be some new way
you have to learn how to do
things, right?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So in other
words, we want to invest in
making sure there's no server
error messages moreso than an
integrated GUI builder.
There are a lot of other
good tools out there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Do we want to
maybe check back to the
Hangout in case there's
someone else live?
I don't want to leave
them hanging.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Anyone
else live on the
Hangout with any questions?
Any questions so far?
OK, great.
Let's go down the list.
Quite a set of interesting
questions here.
Next one's around the data
validation API, which was
available briefly, and then
killed a few weeks before I/O.
I wouldn't say it's killed.
So as you could probably imagine
from that, we're still
working on it.
And keep an eye out.
It's something that
we're looking on.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, people have
been asking for data
validation features
in the Spreadsheet
app for a long time.
And so this is a hint that
there's something cooking.
Unfortunately, it got thrown out
there a little too early.
And so, we had to
reel it back in.
But I think just keep
your eyes out.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Sounds good.
All right, let me see the next
one here is about being able
to pin content directly
to the sidebar.
So once a sidebar is displayed,
there's no good way
to add content to the sidebar.
So you can either have the
sidebar itself aware of where
to get the content from and
using HTML or JavaScript to
append content to it.
Or you can have a reference to
what is displayed manually, as
this question indicates.
And then update it.
And then, we show the sidebar.
As of now, there's no good API
to append or update an already
open sidebar.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I think that's
part of maybe the
difference in flow between the
UI App world and the HTML
service world.
In the UI App, your server
code would do some
manipulations and then throw a
new version out there to you.
Return, and then
update an app.
In HTML service, what we want
you to do is rather than your
server throwing code to the
client, the client has
JavaScript on it that uses
Google Script Run to reach
back to the server, pull out a
fresh copy of the data, and
display it.
And so we're working on making
it so that hopefully someday,
you won't have to do polling
and possibly keep checking
your back end.
But for now, it's a really
powerful way to have a really
responsive UI, too, right?
Because UI App, you had to
wait for the back end.
Now, you can do nice,
little spinners.
People love spinners, and
always had problems with
spinners in UI App.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And timers.
ERIC KOLEDA: Timers.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you can say,
every five seconds, check
for something.
Those things aren't possible
in UI App.
All right, let's see here.
Next question is, any way to get
the footer of a document
so I can remove page numbers
from the first page?
Or are all footers linked
into a single template?
That's a good question.
Do you know the answer
to this?
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, I do know
that in the model, and I think
if we have the model up there
still on the document guide,
there is a difference between
the body, the
header, and the footer.
Unfortunately, I haven't
played with
the footer that much.
So I don't know if things like
page numbers, you can get to
them or remove them.
Certainly, I can see
why it'd be useful.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
So if you find something missing
here, please feel free
to log a feature requests
on our issue tracker.
Next one, two quick ones
here, being able to
access table of contents.
I don't think that's
possible today.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think you can
read them, read their
existence, but not exactly
the list inside of it.
And I don't think you
can edit them today.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Again, if
there's really good use cases,
please put it on the
issue tracker.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think what we're
going to see is that now
you can put scripts directly
into a doc, people are going
to be exploring the doc a lot
more deeply than ever before.
A lot of times, people would
just dump a couple paragraphs
in there, then email
it to somebody.
I think people are going to get
a lot more fine grained.
And so we know that you're
probably going to dust off
some areas that we didn't
quite nail it down.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
Could I create a concept form
through Google Forms with the
App Script HTML service or
dynamically show next questions?
So Google Forms has
its own set of UI.
So you cannot actually use
Google Forms with HTML service
like this question describes.
They're separate technologies.
ERIC KOLEDA: If I'm reading
that one correctly, it's
something that may
be possible.
And actually, I think Matt the
engineer has even thought
about it or tried it out once,
which is to build a form in
Google Forms, then not actually
show it via Google
Forms, but read its data out,
and then display an equivalent
form via HTML service.
So kind of like using the Forms
Designer, but not the
Forms Displayer.
So it's pretty on the edge.
I would not say this is
something that we've tried a
lot or we think we recommend
that you could do it, and it
would be fully successful.
There may be some
issues there.
But I guess the idea is you
could design a form by the
designer, and that just
gives you some model.
And then, you can do whatever
you want with that model.
You could display it as HTML.
You could put it into any
format you want to.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
We really should wrap up here.
We've gone over time.
Lot of good questions.
We had a lot of content.
So I apologize for going
over by a little bit.
Let you guys get back to work,
or sleep, or breakfast,
whichever time zone you're
watching us from.
Thank you very much
for joining.
Thank you for the questions.
And thank you for all the
support around IO.
We're super excited to see what
you can do with these new
APIs and services.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That was great.
And we'll see you for
future episodes of
Google Developers Live.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thanks.